president Trump impossible 2020
Democratic contender Beto O'Rourke
throwing down over the border wall the
pair hosting dueling rallies in El Paso
Texas and wasting little time going
after each other
president Trump bashing bata with these
stinging attacks and beta O'Rourke
responding by going hard when
criticizing president wall
[Applause]
[Music]
security and here's presidents from
laying into the Texan we were all
challenged by a young man who lost an
election to Ted Cruz hey he's supposed
to win in order to run but a young man
who's got very little going for himself
except he's got a great first name
he is he challenged us so we have let's
say 35,000 people tonight and he has 200
people 300 people as for the wall
congressional negotiators have reached a
deal in principle to avoid a new
government shutdown the plan calls for
1.4 billion dollars to build new border
barriers but falls short of the 5.7
billion the president's asking for so
will trump support it here's what he's
saying I never cared about construction
I love construction and I know how to do
it for the right price am I happy at
first glance I just got to see it the
answer is no I'm not I'm not happy but
am I happy with where we're going I'm
thrilled but the Wolves getting bill
regardless doesn't matter all right one
I confess I bought into the bado hype I
thought he was the true believer I
thought he was a real superstar I saw
him last night kind of [ __ ]
gesticulations a lightweight slogans bad
advance work there was a band in the
background empty pair of drums I don't
get it
what's there to get maybe he was
speaking the truth truth was that well
he said what does the wall do it
actually harms people it hasn't stopped
the level of illegal immigrants he said
it sends them around to other places but
exactly it doesn't matter I mean to me
what matters here is the Trump just you
know even in the size of the crowd
things test tells lies he says oh this
guy has three 500 people Bloomberg said
he had that beta O'Rourke had like
10,000 to 15,000 people Trump had at
most according to the fire department
6500 inside and another few thousand
outside I'm glad you mentioned that
because we had our crack team at the 5
investigating Dib crack we investigated
we talked to the Coliseum in the fire
department of Police Department and they
said there were 7500 inside the Trump
rally the whole six that's not true was
8000 M
and six to ten thousand outside so that
was double Oh what better a Roark had
that double fit the old because he
didn't have 15 because the fire
department and the police department
official estimates from is you know what
you are who you have such trouble with
statistic I'm gonna leave it alone but I
will say this I noticed that Donald
Trump last night did not mention
national emergency and so I'm hopeful
that today with the deal that's been
announced we can finally move forward I
know that people like Ann Coulter making
fun of the green New Deal called Trump's
nuit new a compromise here the yellow
New Deal / Trump's the far right is
never going to get off his but when it
comes to this deal but I think for the
best of America hopefully Trump finally
realizes enough with the lies in the
distort the demon know what the
president did bring up with dogs Gregg
let's listen to the tape I like this you
do love your dogs don't you I wouldn't
mind having one honestly but I don't
have any time
how would I look walking a dog on the
White House lawn here's a little phony
phony to me a lot of people say oh you
should get a dog why it's good
politically I said look that's not the
relationship I have with my people we
want to have yeah Obama had a dog I tell
you I love that because he's doing all
politicians are future politicians a
huge favor he's talking about the
typical political cliches that seem
phony you don't have to get a dog if you
don't want a dog you don't have to get a
dog seems a bit phony to me so he's
basically saying for the future you
don't need all this political theatrics
that everybody has to bow to this while
is Warren looked so bad when she tried
the bierce to hold that beer in her
kitchen or when she tried to grab the
kid and even bado last night he sounds
too earnest to be sincere or vice versa
so what what Trump is doing Trump has
opened the door for so many different
types of people to become politicians
because you don't have to play the same
game can I just respond to the whole
walls harm people thing well before you
do can I jump yeah yeah you I think a
lot of people like dogs are getting Dana
I mean I don't think she's at the point
that's not the point I'm talking about
not being fake yeah he doesn't have time
to pet an animal yes Trump is forcing
somebody has to force this clarification
on the Democratic Party because they're
holding two competing ideas at once you
can't have a porous border and have a
country full of free things ok those
things they don't pick you have to pick
one if you want your utopia of free
things then you got to have the greatest
wall ever made because everybody in the
world is gonna come and get the free
stuff so if you don't want a wall then
you gotta be a country that offers zilch
that you come here you get nothing in
fact nobody gets anything because that
in itself is a wall what do you think
about the rallies and the deal in
principle between the negotiators
everyone's upset with the deal which i
think is great
I love people in Washington are unhappy
because they're unpopular and they don't
deserve my happiness they also don't
deserve my tax money let's go to bado
for a second this is someone I I think
he's precious garbage and he drives me
crazy here he is trying to do an
impression of a cool band he's trying to
be a rock star yeah you know people
painted this this image of him and
projected this aura that bait O'Rourke
is a rock star I don't think he's that
good-looking he's a collective soul oh
even worse he's Nickelback I think it
was a beta bust
I mean what's really funny about this
Democrat primary is how much Trump likes
to gin up every one of them and he takes
you he's taking a different one every
day I think no one's gonna have more fun
in this Democratic primary than
president Trump I think you mentioned
yesterday that he was gonna be live
tweeting all the debates but listen the
bottom line of what it comes down to
this deal this wall whatever it's gonna
be there's you know there's a couple of
questions here can the president can he
take this one point three seven five
billion dollars build it on still
barriers anywhere he wants and the deal
so that's important I don't even know
that that's the problem so that's it
that's a question that has to be
answered and what about this 40,000 bed
cap that's something I don't understand
the politics of that one how is that a
winning
little argument that we want to have
less detention beds for illegal force
ice to focus on violent criminals rather
than breaking up families or bothering
people who are just here contributing to
the American economy well what if they
haven't contributed yet what if they
just got caught crossing out I mean
saying you shut down the entitlement
state it's one of the other I'm fine
having a bunch of people come in I'm not
fine giving people free stuff right back
to you all right
Nickelback called and they're very upset
they're being called very bitter you
know very successful band Canadian